i'm still here keeping my fingers
crossed is that something that you may
be given more thought to or consider
listen i love talking about culture
and i love having discussions with
people i'm definitely down to be a part
of that world
i want you guys to set the record
straight on who initiated the first kiss
because miranda pointed this way and
raven pointed this way
it's never gonna happen we've got
miranda
and raven back on celebrity game face
what made you guys want to come back for
more
well we lost the first time and uh
there was i'm just gonna keep it real
like there was a week of just
can can you believe that we lost can you
believe that we lost and
well she would wake up in the morning
and be like we're getting back on that
show we're gonna win again
i was like okay raven and miranda
you guys look intense like you're ready
so okay all right
[Laughter]
miranda i have to tell you obviously
i've been a fan of ravens
for decades and i am you know super
familiar with her brand and her sense of
humor but
really getting to know you and you have
also a pretty sharp tongue you had no
problem telling kevin hart a little quip
here and there
um what has it been like for you to
really put yourself
um in front of the camera and open
yourself up kind of you know to the
media
and the world it's been interesting a
journey
to say the least um raven has obviously
been really helpful
in all of that for me but at the same
time
there oddly is a level of comfort i've
i'm from los angeles i grew up in it my
dad worked in
the entertainment industry i have a lot
of friends within that world i worked in
that world
prior to you know this moment
um so there's a part of it that feels
kind of just
natural it's it's really fun and i feel
really lucky to kind of get to have this
experience now
but um we're also both
smart about how we keep our private
things private and what we do choose to
present and this this was just honestly
really really fun
well i appreciate your wit and your sass
and i don't know if you have a personal
relationship with kevin hart but i love
that you were like
like left and right wow raven did that
surprise you
oh no no no no no i know who i'm married
i know exactly and you have to have that
kind of tongue if you're going to be
with me because i need to be put in my
place here and there and you need to
keep up with me and she definitely
i'm following now which i like which is
not normal for me
ah i like that well i do want you know
you say that you know who you married
but when we were watching you do the
little trivia
the the first game against each other i
want you guys to set the record straight
on who initiated the first kiss because
miranda pointed this way and raven
pointed this way
it's never gonna happen it's just never
gonna happen
because we don't even know the truth of
the matter so it's like it's very hard i
mean i guess we should sit down and like
really just solidify a story maybe even
when we do sit down and solidify it oh
for them yeah
we'll give you a story but for us we
still go back and forth about this
i honestly honestly think it was 50 50.
i think that she gave maybe the word
saying
it's cool and i was like okay here i am
like i think that's kind of i never kiss
first i'm somebody who needs a little i
need to know
it's okay i need a little bit of
permission and it's like i feel like
raven
told me it was okay and then i maybe
leaned in
and then i leaned in as well and then we
both leaned in a little more
and then we were like and then oh it
just happened it wasn't like
yeah because also you don't want to lean
in for a kiss and nobody's ready for it
and just in case it's so it was also so
many years ago who knows i know that's
true and it was dark
wow how many years ago five years
six five or six years ago wow and you
guys managed to really
fly under the radar you're welcome
you know in this industry i feel like
everything gets leaked and there's
photos and there's paparazzi
what was the secret to to keeping things
so low profile
don't say nothing also my invisibility
cloak really helps
so that's been thrown on doing wonders
for us
yes made in uh ginglebug what's it
called uh
was there any trepidation you know being
such a low profile couple for now you're
telling me
five years and then you surprised us all
last summer and announced to the world
that you have married
um was there any trepidation about doing
something
so public when you were used to being so
low-key for so many years
that's a conversation that we had
beforehand knowing this
knowing the the world that i live in and
that she lives in as well we knew that
we knew the ripples it could make and we
assessed
the ripples it couldn't have made so we
definitely sat down and planned the
whole thing
we are not ignorant to the fact that
when something so big
comes out especially for me who has been
private with their lives
and their dating life for so long so we
were prepared
um we weren't prepared for how fast it
took off and how many
people showed love we were pleasantly
surprised
we were grateful and thankful for all
the love that came our way and still
comes our way
and you know it's like we're adults we
both have kind of a child complex
so when this happens it's like oh oh
that's right we're married like i still
get a kick out of it
congratulations it's been about i think
a little over six months
since you've tied the knot uh we're
still here in quarantine
how is life and and how is married life
married life and that whole world is
wonderful and beautiful and
um you know we're having a great time
we are having a great time we're we have
done a lot
personally we sold the house we you know
moved we bought another place and
another place we're trying to set up
life
so that you know eventually we can just
sit and be old and
get chips and
and um decorating and finding
crafts and projects for us to do
on the work end and for our personal
life and
you know we think that we're makeshift
therapists so i totally
am there's no question about that i just
want to quickly ask
raven the last time i spoke with you in
july about uh raven about bunked
yeah our interview completely blew up
when i asked you
if you would ever consider revisiting
your daytime tv roots maybe joining your
girl adrian
on the reel i'll never say no to a cool
job i don't mind helping out where they
need me to
as long as we're corona safe i'm down
for the cause but my trajectory
in my head now that i'm married and you
know i'm
soon gonna start a family and you know
need to do that i want to make sure i'm
um getting into a job position that
allows me
time to myself because let's not forget
how demanding that job was before corona
and i'm sure it's demanding now
did you have any idea that that story
would get so much attention
and i'm still here keeping my fingers
crossed is that something that you may
be given more
thought to or consider listen i love
talking about culture and i love having
discussions with people
if there is a a project
that would uh benefit from my crazy
mind i'm definitely down to be a part of
that world
i think that there's something rich in
being able to communicate about pop
culture especially since i've been a
part of it since i was three years old
and she's keeping me abreast of all the
people that i didn't know like that's a
good i have like a new encyclopedia
right now
sure i'd love to one day